i want to talk about what we go over
because i got so many texts this week
because she attacked me the week before
so she was everybody was like oh bill i
get you're enjoying the karma first of
all i'm going to talk about this at the
end of my show next week teaser but uh
there is no [ __ ] thing as karma okay
get over that
whoopee
attacks me on a regular basis she says
stupid [ __ ] on a regular basis it just
happened to go inside but
can i just say this
i had on last week ira glasser former
long-time head of the aclu talking about
free speech will be goldberg who by the
way i hope is still a friend we can
disagree with each other should not
be canceled or put off her show as much
as i totally disagree with her crazy
statement
free speech she should be there she
shouldn't get a timeout
not every single thing has to be for
everybody right we can have platforms
that have stuff on them that not
everyone on that platform or who consume
stuff on that platform enjoys and the
view is a particularly weird place to do
a cancellation
it's called the view it's called the
view it's not called the facts yeah but
it's but isn't it interesting
that it's called it's uh i mean i don't
think they meant this when barbara
walters invented it a long time ago but
it's the view well that's the problem in
america there is one view right and
that's clearly true opinion and
everybody else can go sit in the corner
that's
correct i think that's not actually
you're right the name raises questions
and certainly there's been some
uh much covered internal politics on
that show but i do think that you know
there is space
even that show does have space when when
whoopi said what she said
there was quick pushback from other
panelists they were like oh i don't know
actually i think that might not be
that's it mission accomplished we talked
about it can we just understand that
part of our sorry racial history in this
country
is that the point of view from a black
person is often going to be very
different and sometimes shocking to a
white person i pulled the quote from
when whoopi defended michael vick
remember michael vick was the football
player who was electrocuting dogs
and i'm a lifelong peta board member
you know
okay
also
also someone who believes the nazis were
very racist okay oh yeah but
here's what she said about michael vick
he's from the south this is part of his
cultural upbringing for a lot of people
dogs are sport
instead of just saying he's a beast and
he's a monster this is a kid who comes
from a culture where this is not
questioned
okay you see the point here again i
don't agree with her on michael vick but
we grew up in two different worlds which
the white people imposed upon the black
people they are going to ver sometimes
have a very different opinion and the
answer is not to make them sit in a
corner for two weeks that is insulting
it's so insulting to make a 65 year old
i mean
the person at abc news said i've asked
you to take time to reflect and learn
about the impact of her comments reflect
how insulting for someone of her age
who's a sophisticated person and that
the impact of her comment there is no
impact there aren't
neo-nazis waiting for the green light
from the lady on the view
to go out and do a new crystal knot
and the the whole point of free speech
is we don't need free speech when we're
right when everyone agrees
we need free speech when we're wrong we
need free speech to make mistakes we
need free speech to say really unpopular
things and one of the things i'm one of
the reasons i'm always proud to come on
this show now i suspect you feel the
same way catherine is this is the only
space left on television where people
can speak freely and not be terrified
right
i just want to say that you know i'm
unconscious
that you have the scars on your back for
fighting to keep you there from 9 11.
sure i'll get them tonight right and
it's hugely to your credit that you've
fought to do that right it's hard finish
your thought
no let him talk
you